I want to ask you about the dating side
of things so you mentioned that you know
you get the wisdom from being slightly
older dating has definitely changed for
a younger generation to some degree in
terms of the method so obviously like
Tinder [__] blew up and now we have
this new period of only fans and
especially where I am based in Asia like
lots of Oni fans models everywhere you
go like that is to me that severely
impacted a male's perception of what a
partner should be or what a partner
could be so when you find a partner it's
like well this
promiscuous girl over here could have
equally been my partner I want to get
your thoughts on like what you think the
impact of like only fans will be on
Mal's perceptions only fans is a recent
phenomenon you know it's funny you
mentioned online dating and Tinder and
the phenomenon of of meeting the
opposite sex online isn't new um I met
my ex-wife on a dating site called lava
life and there was dating sites that
were even bigger than that around the
time Plenty of Fish lemon tonic I think
you know there's a lot of these dating
sites in the early 2000s that just came
out because the internet came out it's
like you know sex cells so obviously you
know dating and introduction online seem
to be like where it started to pick up
it wasn't until we had apps on uh mobile
devices where you just swipe left and
right like Tinder and Bumble that made
things so much easier because we like
easy we like insta gratification we like
a you know quick and easy match and
opportunity to open on that very quickly
so to the point of only fans again you
know this is a recent a more newer
phenomenon that exists a lot of women
use it today uh what is only fans is it
prostitution not really because they're
generally not having sex with these guys
and let's be honest these guys that are
throwing money at women to subscribe to
their only fans to get pictures of their
butthole or whatever they're getting
they're not society's best right they're
not the kind of guys that these gals
want to be with they're just simps and
all they're doing is they're throwing
money at these girls and they're
collecting it and these guys are doing
it under the hopes or the guys that
maybe one day they can meet them or you
know some something will happen so it's
a losers game from that perspective now
if I'm a guy dating and I meet a gal and
I find out that she has an only fans
okay so the frame part of it you know
comes into play if I'm going to consider
a gal in my life and let's say it's a
long-term relationship an LTR I'm going
to want to make sure she's in my frame
I'm going to make sure that she's not
doing anything to compromise the
relationship I want to make sure she's
not doing anything to embarrass me I'm
rich Cooper I wrote the unplugged Alpha
imagine if Society found out that my
girlfriend and only fans could you
imagine that would be absurd that would
be ridiculous you know that I would
allow something like that right so I
mean if she has an only fans and she
likes it and I'm a single guy let's say
and I think she's fun or maybe she
becomes a friends with Ben I just
wouldn't take her seriously she's just a
girl selling pictures of her butthole
online promiscuity is rampant out there
women are indulging and men are
indulging and I don't think that's going
to change it seems like that seems to be
ramping up so the angle that I that I
would personally take is date spin
plates which all that means is just date
multiple women simultaneously not
monogamously and then if I'm open to a
long-term relationship which I think
most guys are then you're essentially
going to let the cream rise to the top
wait for her to come to you and say
Where Do We Stand rich I dig your Vibe I
don't want to share you I want to claim
you you know like the standard sort of
stuff and then that's when you can take
a look at their life and say well I like
you too and I've been having a good time
but I'm not going to take a gal
seriously that goes out to lunch you
know every two weeks with her
ex-boyfriend I'm not going to take a gal
seriously that runs an only fans I'm not
going to take a gal seriously that has
you know 20,000 followers on her public
Instagram and she's continuously posting
pictures of herself in a bikini or low
cut cleavage or exposing a lot of K skin
I'm not interested in that right so I
mean where are you at with this like is
this something that you're taking
seriously like is this your life choice
is this your career to be an only fans
model to be an Instagram influencer
right like is this a real job do you
make money at it you know sort of thing
these are some of the questions that I
would have to ask right and you know
when you're dating out there and you're
dealing with these women I just I mean
generally speaking I don't think that I
could look at a woman that's that's
posted pictures of herself naked online
whether they're paid for or not doesn't
matter to me it's disgusting women are
valued based on their beauty and their
purity a woman that shared her body with
a 100 men is less valuable than a woman
that shared her body with one man for 12
years because she was in a long-term
relationship you see what I'm saying so
you have to evaluate these things when
you're dealing with women in your life
and be again fastidious about it and you
know decisive about the kind of women
that you're going to deal with if you
want to have those options if you want
to have the option to say no to women
which most guys don't first girl that
touches his his peeee you know he gets
all excited and wants to marrier you
know for the most part but when you have
options when you're a high value guy
when you're doing something else with
your life more than just chasing tail
you chase Excellence then you have the
opportunity to say no thank you and you
you know and then you just let her go
and then you pick better women and then
you choose women that are choosing you
right for men that are in that let's say
top 40% bracket 50 to 40% bracket who
don't have that much choice but also
like are not that fat like how do they
approach that because they may feel like
they don't have the confidence to be
like Oh I'm going to have multiple
partners or I'm going to say no because
like if some girl who's semi
historically like an average guy can't
you know they never have in the past and
I think the Guinness Book of World
Records has him on a known record for
having the most children they don't know
the exact number but apparently it's
over a thousand he had multiple wives he
had multiple concubines um he would have
Unix he would he would hire Unix he
would make men Unix to to guard his Herm
of women and they were all exclusive
with him and he would just pound out
babies like that was this thing if
you're going to run multiple women I
mean if you're going to run a Herm if
you're going to be polygynous you know
for example you have to have something
going on in your life like you have to
be a high value guy women will only
share a high value Alpha in fact women
are more apt to share a high high value
Alpha than be straddled with a faithful
loser it's why women would rather date a
rich successful doctor that's married
than a broke loser that lives in his
mom's basement with a neck beard smoking
dubes all day playing video games for a
career they'd rather be with a guy
that's done something else with his life
because he also has pre-selection too
because he's got a wife right this is
how women operate and this is a
uncomfortable truth that bugs a lot of
people you know when I say these things
there's people watching this or hearing
this right now that're that are getting
very upset like visibly upset they don't
like it they want tune out but you know
what you can be upset about it than a
broke loser that lives in his mom's
basement with a neck beard smoking dubes
all day playing video games for a career
they'd rather be with a guy that's done
something else with his life because he
also has pre-selection too because he's
got a wife right this is how women
operate and this is a uncomfortable
truth that bugs a lot of people and when
I say these things there's people
watching this or hearing this right now
that are that are getting very upset
like visibly upset they don't like it
they want to tune out but you know what
you can be upset about it it doesn't
make it untrue it's factual why do you
think women Chase men with status
because status is really important to
women right I mean if you go back
through history and you know you set
aside all the modern tropes and lies you
know stories that we've heard about
prince princess one man one woman you
know sort of thing women in the past
have almost always shared men we are
essentially nomadic hunter gatherers and
we've lived that way for a very long
time it's I think it's only in the last
6,000 years in modern history where
we've indulged in things you know cities
communities uh markets um trade uh
stores of value you know were considered
for millions of years prior to that we
were nomadic hunter gatherers we lived
in small tribes that sort of moved
around and the men would go out and hunt
and the women would sort of you know
gather whatever was around the village
and take care of the the children and
that's the way things have always
operated and women would be shared
amongst the highest value men within
that tribe I mean like even today if you
go to the Amazon you know you go to the
Amazon on Bas deep within you know the
woods and the forest these tribes that
have had no exposure to Modern culture
helicopters skyscrapers you know things
like that things that are completely
foreign to them that's how they still
operate today right you know there's
still modern version of ancient hunter
gatherers where women generally share
the highest value Alphas in the tribe
it's not always that way but that seems
to be the common way in like monogamy is
very uncommon in in the animal kingdom
it's it's it's very very uncommon um
it's only become common in humans over
the last you know several thousand years
because it's be it's become inforce then
you've got religion then you've got
marriage all of these things uh you know
that sort of modify and play on us
differently but we are we are both
polygynous and we are both somewhat
monogamish I wouldn't say monogamy um
exists you know within humans because
true monogamy as it exists in the animal
kingdom like if you look at birds for
example that are monogamous if one of
the birds dies that's it there's no
other bird after that you know they just
live as a widow you know sort of thing
like that's the way that mon monogamy
operates in the wild but in humans we
like to claim monogamy but we're more
monogamish because we because it's one
person at a time right it's like you
know women that will date a bunch of
guys or be in relationships you know
with a bunch of guy it's always funny
because you know you know if a gal's
been with 20 say let's use an easy Light
number like that and then she meets a
guy and then he says to her okay you
know I dig your Vibe sort of thing
whatever and she wants to claim to be
monogamous right you know she wants to
be exclusive with him well she's already
shared her body with 20 other guys how
is how is she monogamous right I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out